new signs of a false surge and perhaps
an even more painful winter as
coronavirus cases
soar in the u.s the rise in the
infection rate is rapidly filling
hospitals in all but eight states the
exceptions being hawaii
california arizona idaho wyoming
north dakota georgia and vermont it
comes as the country saw nearly 70 000
new cases on friday that is the most
in a single day since july it pushed the
overall number of infections over 8
million
and the death toll to more than 218
thousand people
michael george begins our coverage here
in new york this morning michael good
morning
jeff good morning new york is in the
midst of new shutdowns in some areas as
cases continue to rise in a handful of
neighborhoods
and what's happening here is happening
in much of the country
a concerning sign for experts as we
approach the holidays the coronavirus
rate appears to be
increasing not decreasing
in wisconsin one in every four
coronavirus tests are coming back
positive
residents are asked to avoid gatherings
even
political gatherings we're here to call
on president trump to cancel
his campaign rally on saturday dr bob
friedland along with other wisconsin
doctors
stepped up friday to urge cancellation
of the president's rally tonight in the
state
president trump's rallies endanger
public health and they have become
platforms for him to spread
medically inaccurate information
wisconsin is one of at least
seven states that in the past two days
has set
records for infections and there's no
mystery about what's causing case
numbers to rise retirement parties
birthday parties baby showers weddings
all of those things in kansas city eight
area hospitals have had to turn away
patients this week in new mexico a
second
straight day of record-breaking cases
friday and
hospitalizations we're not succeeding at
combating the virus this is the most
serious emergency that new mexico
has ever faced yet
in california the attractions and parks
association are petitioning to open up
disneyland but the governor is not
swayed
we don't anticipate in the immediate
term
any of these larger theme parks opening
until we see more stability
and the push for halloween as usual got
pushed back
in salem massachusetts there are no
bands there are no djs there are no
fireworks
there's not the typical array of
activities you would see on halloween
but nearly eight months into the
pandemic and facing a worsening covid
crisis
there's still no unified response on
what to do
dr anthony fauci addresses that on 60
minutes
this sunday in an interview with cbs
news chief medical correspondent dr
john lapook how bad would things have to
get for you to advocate
a national lockdown they'd have to get
really really bad
first of all the country is fatigued
with restrictions so we want to use
public health
measures not to get in the way
of opening the economy
earlier in the week dr fauci told cbs
news he believes a vaccine could become
widely available
by april dana all right michael thank
you